good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to this press conference
following the article 50 European
Council on BRICS it first I might Donald
Tusk the President of the European
Council to take the wrong thank you
Drebin
good evening if you know we devoted
today if European Council meeting to
brexit Prime Minister my repeated
request to extend the article 50 period
until the 30th of June and to approve
the so-called Strasbourg agreement
during the discussion among the year 27
the readers approached this request in a
positive spirit the European Council
decided to approve the Strasbourg
agreement as regards the extension our
decisions and visit two scenarios in the
first scenario that is if the withdrawal
agreement is passed by the House of
Commons next week the European Council
agrees to an extension until the 22nd of
May in the second scenario that is if
the visual agreement is not approved by
the House of Commons next week the
European Council agrees to an extension
until the 20th of April 12th 12th of
April
[Laughter]
while expecting the UK to indicate a way
forward what this means in practice is
that until death date all options will
remain open and the cliff edge dates
will be delayed the UK government will
still have a choice of a deal how do you
a long extension revoking article 50 the
12th of April is a key date in terms of
the UK deciding whether to hold European
Parliament elections if it has now
decided to do so by then the option of a
long extension will automatically become
impossible if you know in accordance
with the treaties any extension must be
decided unanimously by the eu27 an
agreement with the member state
concerned this is why I met Prime
Minister my several times tonight to
make sure that the UK accepts the
extension scenarios and I am pleased to
confirm that we have reached an
agreement on this thank you thank you
and now the president of the European
Commission jean-claude Juncker ladies
and gentlemen since that day of the
referendum the position of the 27 member
states and the Commission has been
United and unequivocal we have worked
tirelessly to negotiate to build all
agreement we have done everything we
could to help cut it over the finishing
line we were asked for clarifications in
December we gave them we were asked for
assurances in January we gave them
I was asked for further assurances last
Monday in Strasbourg notably with regard
to the backstep I gave them
and so I have to welcome that today the
27 leaders endorsed the legally binding
clarification assurances that Prime
Minister may and I agreed in star book
this closes and completes the full
package there is no more than we can
live we are hopeful that the agreement
will be adopted by the House of Commons
madam MS your quacky ladies and
gentlemen
whatever happens we are ready for every
eventuality including the absence of an
agreement on brexit and so-called No
Deal we're ready and we've been rare
days since 2017
emergency measures are in place and
we're continuing to prepare we adopted
19 negative proposals to tackle the main
problems a hard brexit would create
particularly on air and road links and
citizens bus fishing commissioners have
been to all capitals to discuss national
preparations and emergency plans ladies
and gentlemen this has been a long haul
but we've got to look forward now the
clock is ticking not only for brexit but
for other things too we've got to
deliver things for the European citizens
321 legislative proposals have gone
through Parliament and council since we
started in this commission we've got to
move forward tomorrow we'll be talking
about our relations with China we'll be
talking about industrial policy and
we'll be talking about our
competitiveness
these are important essential things for
europeans and this is what our main job
is the floor for a few questions as we
start right here please
hello it's James Chris from B Daily
Telegraph it's a question for both
presidents please how long is a long
extension please until the very end
Calvin Lee at the BBC a question again
for both presidents first of all can you
describe the atmosphere in the room my
understanding is that Theresa May was
actually prepared and surprisingly to
some for No Deal if that becomes a
scenario almost backing away to say if
it is no deal that's where it goes and
also do you feel that there's a big risk
of just kicking the can down the road
now
the atmosphere was much better than I
expected and social better than for
example in December not only because of
the weather but also because of the
molten but frankly speaking it's a
remotest not the most important thing
here our discussion was really really
constructive and and I can only confirm
that what I felt not only today but also
before it's a good will and
determination I know all of us how
objectively how difficult the situation
is and the fact that we that we are
still able to find a not the final
solution of course not but but the way
to do it is to ease the process for both
sides I think it's it was very very
tangible and visible I'm very satisfied
especially that we that we have still
open so many options and mmm it means
that you know what is my personal view
indifferent highly satisfied and I think
it's a good sign because frankly
speaking I was really sad father how a
meeting and now I am much more
optimistic also do you still move are
good the atmosphere was good
and well we have yet to see quite what
the limits of our patients are Katherine
fury reporter president and president
askew said a while ago that there was a
special place in hell for those who
promoted brexit without a plan well with
withdrawal agreement is part of a plan
if British MPs don't vote for it next
week do you think that special place in
Hale should be enlarged to include more
members of the House of Commons and
since May speech last night more than
two million people have signed a
petition to support the revocation of
article 50 would you welcome this thank
you according to to our Pope the hell is
still empty you know and it means that
it's a lot of spaces
I think this is the right moment to
conclude the press conference don't go
to hell